it was a very daunting challenge going
into it
you know I was lucky enough to surround
myself with with people like the people
here tonight who had worked with a lot
so I had the security of people around
me who would make sure I wasn't making a
mess of it and you know to have that
kind of community of people really helps
you you know it gives you a support and
also an infrastructure you're used to
working with well there's no one quite
like charlise and you know she was born
to play this part I think she really you
know takes it to another level so
putting her in those kind of clothes was
a good marriage she she's you know
absolutely you know knows how to work a
costume like a pro and and it was you
know a creative process with her and and
she you know did make a journey from
kind of a hopeful queen to a sort of you
know decayed mass but but and her
costumes followed suit in this story and
she really wanted to convey that in her
acting and and in you know the story of
the Queen rather than having it be a
sort of OneNote wonder we wanted to use
castles that would have been around then
obviously embellished them much more a
fairytale nature and I think it really
helps the actors and rupert in the
direction having a real tangible space
obviously we couldn't build all of it
but we did our best to build as much as
we possibly could and I think we thought
quite a bit it worked well at the
beginning it was really the dwarf that
was the big thing because before we
start shooting it was like you know
Rupert had this idea to use you know all
those British actors and that's great
idea you know an hour in the movie and
there is many shots and you know we have
somewhat you know a limited schedule to
shoot and I wanted Roo to be able to
Rupert to be able to to to have a
maximum freedom so we had to come up
with kind of old-school things really I
mean
like you see those guys and they're
there most of the time everybody else is
walking on rostrum which is just higher
than anybody else we framed them a
little bit differently so so it looks
like we framed them like little people
but really they're just normal guys and
then we and then we cut their leg leg
really digitally to to make them to make
them look short but we had to do so many
shots and and we had four months of five
months of post-production epiphany with
the dwarfs was the first time you see
them you know you should do a green
screen shrinking shot and once the
audience sees them they go wow it's them
and and the epiphany for me is he
brought in a little quick time he's very
excited as I group it I have to show you
this after shows and it's basically him
in his wife's leather trousers as a
dwarf kind of doing that and he did and
shortened his arms and and then we knew
you know we had the technique to do that
we put them through dwarfs cool as well
all the actors had their own did it
their own double so they're all you know
learning to walk like each other and do
exercises together and and it was you
know ian mcshane and his cowboy boots
trying to walk like it to office was a
memory that will stay with me but also
Bob Hoskins had a girl he had a
proportional we used everyone
proportional so they they had a
different kind of dwarfism so he'd of
his little girl on his lap with his
beard and long hair and they'd be
chatting away him with his old gruff
cockney voice and little high-pitched
chirping voice is very there was a very
sweet moment it was very funny actually
where he was a little fun it certainly
wasn't anybody's first time but it was a
big time for all of us for you know
having that many soldiers and that many
for you know the total looks all the
dwarf things with the little people and
the real the actors and the combinations
of all those things was was a huge
challenge and you know I have to say we
had tremendous support on the film you
know we've made a big film that that
hopefully is successful but III hope has
a heart to it and some kind of message
we're not pushing any kind of
you know beauty messages but I think
there's things in there that I hope
people you know will be will somehow be
affected by I think so many big films
just sparkle in front of your eyes and
you leave and and you know you've spent
your popcorn money and you know you know
you've spent a lot of money and you
don't leave with anything staying with
you and I hope just something in here
stays with you even if it's a small
image of a you know a child's eye or
something I just you know the films that
I love have scarred me for life in a
good way not in a terrifying way I mean
films like you know Nick rogues films
they're just images that really you know
become part of you know I hope there's
you know just one thing in here that
people will take home